i want to start with montreal in 2012.
every night for months and months we
marched endless crowds of students
filling the city's arteries every night
as the sun went down
and every single night after rinsing off
the tear gas
tired from running through the city i
went to sleep truly deeply feeling in my
bones that another world was possible
that this was something important and
unprecedented and unstoppable
and that tomorrow everything could be
different for me as a young american
student who grew up with the assumption
of going into debt for college
when i first heard that quebec students
would go on strike to fight less than 2
000 canadian dollars and propose tuition
hikes
and further that organizers were
demanding that higher education be
tuition free
i'll admit at first i was shocked at the
absurdity and the grandiosity of that
idea
but the unions leading these protests
took a longer view forward imaginations
fueled by the potential found in a
longer view back
support for free education view grew
popular discussed in the mainstream
i'd only joined in once the movement was
underway without realizing it had
actually been in the works for much
longer
through a history of previous waves and
coalition building that had only just
come to a head
researching quebec student movement
history i learned that in the 60s
more conservative students commonly
called for a tuition freeze with
centrists demanding free tuition
while the progressive call at the time
was for students to be salaried
these expansions of what's possible
reminded me of a recent seminar about
long-term thinking
with dr lonnie j avi brooks describing
how queer afrofuturisms can serve to
widen our aperture for the future
instead of viewing the possibilities the
future holds through a narrow straw
limited in our imagination with a wider
view we see how much more could be
possible
this insight into the normalization of
free higher education 50 years ago
and again in 2012 helped me see how
limited my thinking had been
it took me much longer to catch up to
those earlier change makers with wider
views
when i saw only my more narrow cone of
possible features a wider aperture could
even drive accelerated change
and access to these preferable features
so what other possible features could we
be missing out on with our traditional
narrow
views there are bigger visions better
possible worlds that we miss out on
without this
how can we get there with this to this
viewpoint where more is possible
the abolition movement today is a
powerful example of widening our
collective
possible futures window abolishing the
police and prison industrial complex is
shocking to many today
but to propose it to consider it and to
demand it inherently widens the realm of
what's possible for the benefit of all
of us
angela davis and mariam cabba's insights
they of course have led amazing work
here and i've learned so much from it
their insights on building systems for
community safety and harm reduction with
the potential to grow until they might
make traditional policing obsolete
show that we can build pockets of the
future that we want today functioning
alongside and within present systems
alternatives to policing have been being
explored and built by black activist
leaders for well before many white
activists like me became aware of the
idea at all
like the black panthers work to
establish free food systems and other
community programs
black organizers have long set some of
the best examples for this kind of world
building as a futurist
activist tactic in this way sometimes
the future already actually exists
recognizing that the present might be
wider and more diverse than we thought
also widens our lens into the future
and identifying these preferable
features in the world today helps us
reset that timeline
another challenge where we need to
incorporate these long view tactics is
climate change
this is a still from alexandria
ocasio-cortez's film project a message
from the future which envisions a
near-term future scenario to help us
imagine what the ambitious green new
deal could do
you can't be what you can't see the
green new deal and also the rewiring
america work as well
pushes our apertures by proposing
alternative visions for our future
with these frameworks we're armed with
detailed plans to ground further
imaginations
just painting the picture of what's
possible helps us widen our apertures
too
but i guess we could also do nothing
we've seen in california recently the
first hand effects that this has
made all too real and i think it's clear
that this is less preferable but still a
possible future
but this is business as usual the path
of least resistance
other futures are urgently needed to be
imagined to prevent that from happening
together these imagine expanded views
give us new ideas for futures to work
toward
they power the ability to normalize
moonshot ideas into the mainstream
and provide a platform for expanding
experiments today as future solutions
they remind us that for any movement we
need to look back further to understand
its deeper vision and further ahead to
see its true potential
i'm hoping that these stories can serve
as a reminder that long-term thinking in
itself can change the world
and even help us feel tomorrow and that
there are many different ways to engage
with these possibilities
i mean it can all benefit you from more
voices being brought into the
conversation
so at its core any work to identify
imagine or build better worlds can
change the present
looking further into what's possible
allows us to see this wider range
illuminating possible better
alternatives that could be filtered out
as unrealistic in a shorter view
or preventing us from being distracted
by incremental
ideas so another world is possible
tomorrow it could all be different
i carry that feeling with me from
montreal that physical sense of shouting
in the streets giving me a real
tangible sense of what's next through
world building today and long-term
thinking forward and back
we have so many possibilities to move
toward please be in touch if you'd like
to talk more about this
thank you and i can't wait to build new
worlds with you